do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Song of Ice and Fire
video in today's video I want to discuss
some of the things George RR Martin's
said during a recent interview during
this interview george RR martin explains
why the winds of winter is taking so
long to write since we all are a Song of
Ice and Fire fans I figured everyone
would be interested in hearing what
George had to say so let's go ahead and
take a look George or Martin is headed
to Chicago in a couple days to receive
the Carl Sandburg literary award and to
give a couple of interviews ahead of his
touchdown in my home town he's talking
to the Chicago Tribune John kasib out
Game of Thrones A Song of Ice and Fire
and why the winds of winter has taken so
long to write Cass covered a wide range
of topics starting with how Martin feels
about having millions of fans out there
eager to read wins the long awaited six
book in his saga predictably Martin says
it's a mixed blessing for many writers
Martin explains the problem is getting
noticed at all he has a very different
issue
I do indeed have millions of people
waiting for the book to come out which
is very gratifying but some of them are
extremely impatient and some of them are
full of their own ideas about the fates
of the various characters I am glad they
can get so emotionally involved with the
characters but sometimes I yearn for the
days when I could just work and quiet
obscurity but those days are gone for me
I'm afraid this is the reality of my
life now indeed it is and let's all
remember that his time is occupied with
far more than a Song of Ice and Fire now
you know that hulu is developing the
series a wild card stories he edits into
a series on top of the winds of winter
he's also writing more Dunkin egg
stories and another volume of fire and
blood on TV he's executive producing an
HBO adaption of who fears death and of
course there are those Game of Thrones
prequel shows waiting in the wings the
success of the show and the success of
other things has injected a lot of other
aspects into my life so sometimes I lay
in bed at night and I'm not thinking
about Westeros I'm thinking about some
other problem I'm having one of the
other shows I'm involved with or
line on an anthology I'm editing or
something that's happening with the
nonprofit organization I started all of
these other things are filling my head
and that is one of the things that's
delayed me I really have to get wins
done I have to put myself on a state
where I'm not being distracted by other
stuff in that period of time at night is
filled with the voices of Tyrion
Lannister and Arya Stark and the other
fictional characters who live inside of
me that's opposed to how he prefers to
work when he has the time to luxuriate
in his invented world and is free to
think about it unburdened if my writing
is going well and I'm really in Westeros
it does haunt me day and night he said
I'm laying there in bed I'm waiting to
go to sleep the lights are out in this
scenes that I'm gonna write tomorrow or
in my head
or maybe the scenes I'm gonna write next
week or maybe the scenes from a
different chapter I can't control it but
something starts filling my head and the
characters start coming alive and I
start hearing snatches a dialogue and I
drift asleep with Westeros and ice and
fire in my head haunting me all of that
adds up to a lot of distraction although
it's lesson since the main show ended
there was a period where the show caught
and passed me and I hadn't anticipated
that happening so there was a tremendous
amount of stress on me a few years ago
when that was about to happen but hadn't
happened yet and I was desperately
trying to finish wins and stay ahead
Martin remembered and it didn't work the
amount of stress that was on me at that
time slowed me down rather than speeding
me up now that the show's over any
stress in that regard is done but of
course we have five successful shows in
various stages of development and one of
them that just finished shooting the
pilot episode in Northern Ireland and
another one that's very close to getting
a pilot order I'm involved with those as
well
Game of Thrones that particular story
may be over on TV but it's not over for
me I still have these two more books to
write and there's other stories in the
world of Westeros which is an entire
world and I'm still deeply involved with
those so believe me there's plenty to
keep me busy so Martin for better or
worse has a lot on his mind
I do sometimes wish it had happened to
me 30 years ago rather than happening to
me at my age because it does kind of
wear me out sometimes he said but I
still have a fair amount of energy and I
still get a fair amount done it's kind
of ironic isn't it if a Song of Ice and
Fire were less popular it would probably
get finished faster but then we wouldn't
want it so bad food for thought finally
cash did ask Martin about the backlash
to the final season of Game of Thrones
coming as close as anyone if I heard an
interview tab right saying he didn't
like season 8 and criticizing share
winners David Benioff and Dan Weiss from
botching the Big Finish Martin did
pretty much the only thing he could do
in that situation I'm not gonna comment
on that he said there are two different
forms the same story when I finished my
books read them but other than that
that's not something I want to get into
since george RR martin is still working
on the other shows at HBO i don't think
we will be hearing him criticized David
and Dan just yet HBO is still filling
his pockets with millions of dollars so
he probably doesn't want to rock that
boat but somewhere down the line I could
see him finally giving his opinion on
how everything worked out we shall see
anyways the main reason why I decided to
read this is because I know we are all
still waiting for the winds of winter to
get released like he said in the
interview it's very hard for him to
focus on the one book when he has so
many other projects in the works not to
mention it has to be incredibly
difficult to bring the story to a close
when it's already so complex I still
happen to think he's very close to
getting it done but how many of you
think we will get ones of one hour by
the end of next year if you remember
correctly
George more or less said that we will
get the book next year or else he will
allow himself to be thrown in jail now I
do want to stay optimistic about this
but I also cannot hold my breath because
he already missed so many deadlines now
I obviously love that George is working
on the new successor shows because that
gives them the best chance of being well
successful but we also have to
understand that the more time and energy
he puts into the other projects the more
time and energy is taken away from
finishing the winds of winter I guess
you could say it's a double-edged sword
you have to take the good with the bad
now let me know down below which would
you rather have at this point
would you rather George spent his time
help writing several shows or would you
rather him just finish the book before
he focuses on anything else
leave me some of your opinions in the
comment section also let me know what
other videos you would like to see me
make I'm always open for suggestions I
want to thank everyone for stopping by
and I also want to thank everyone for
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day bye